hey Vsauce Michael here do you want my
head delivered to your door in a box
well too bad I only have one head and I
already called dibs on it plus my neck
is like pure muscle this head ain't
never coming off the next best thing is
what actually comes in the curiosity box
by Vsauce it is chock full of science
gear designed by us it's pretty amazing
and a portion of all proceeds go to
Alzheimer's research so a subscription
isn't just good for your brain it's good
for all of our brains now if you
subscribe right now there's still time
to get this box the latest one it is
full of brain food including the topic
of this video a gyroscope if you hold a
gyroscope in the palm of your hand
upright like this it will fall over
that's not very surprising you see the
trick is to take the included string and
thread it through a hole and then spin
the disc around to the string wraps
around and around and around and around
once it's sufficiently wound up hold the
outside and give the string a firm pull
ah yeah now the gyroscope appears to
defy gravity the axis that spins around
is like glued in place almost cosmically
if you could get this to spin long
enough you could actually watch as that
access did move but not because it
actually moved because you and earth
moved around it that's actually where it
gets its name gyro scope you can use it
to scope watch the gyro gyration
rotation of the earth as léon foucault
did in 1852 when the device got its name
but how does it work
why are spinning things so stable also
watch this if I give it a good spin and
then hang it from its own string
sideways
it will remain parallel to the ground
but process around to get to the bottom
of what's up or whether as the cool kids
are saying nowadays begin by imagining
yourself swinging a ball around your
head on a rope even though the ball is
following a curved path its velocity is
at any given instant straight tangent to
its path you can demonstrate this to
yourself by letting go the ball will
shoot out at the velocity it had at the
moment you let go it doesn't curve away
or fly directly away while rotating the
rope keeps the ball always at the same
distance from the center which means
continuously changing the direction of
the balls velocity now that requires
force and in this case that force is
delivered by tension in the rope the
same intermolecular forces that attract
neighboring rope molecules to each other
and are the reason the rope doesn't just
disintegrate also resists the balls
momentum acting on it such that its
velocity changes every next instant so
as to always follow a circular path this
Center seeking force that acts on the
ball is called a centripetal force it
can be provided by a rope an entire disk
of material something invisible like
gravity or from the other side by a wall
or banked track side note notice that
there is no force acting on the ball
that goes directly outward away from the
center what we often hear called a
centrifugal or centrifugal force you
know the force you seem to feel when you
lock hands with someone and you both
spin around and you feel pulled straight
back
or when a car urine turns quickly and
you're suddenly thrown away from the
center the thing is this seemingly
outward directed force isn't a force at
all it's actually just an object's
inertia the path the object would take
if no other forces acted on it being
blocked by a force a centripetal force
across sufficiently short timescales an
inertial path can seem like it's
opposite a centripetal force but if
allowed to follow its inertial path for
a while the difference becomes more
clear here is a ball in orbit if the
centripetal force is removed it will
continue along on a path tangent to its
previous circular one the outline
represents where the ball would be if it
hadn't have been released now at first
the separation between the two appears
to occur directly away from the center
straight out but if allowed to continue
a more interesting path emerges from the
perspective of the outline which is
still moving counterclockwise the solid
ball appears to be receding and dragging
behind clockwise this is due to the
Coriolis effect which we will talk about
soon but first let's push some stuff
around it could really be anything but I
would love to use this ball it's very
cool it has fiber optic properties it
would be awesome to get these into
curiosity boxes down the line I will see
what I can do anyway if I push the ball
it will move in the direction of my
force pretty simple but if the ball is
moving before I touch it its velocity
doesn't just disappear instead both
combine and the ball moves according to
their sum the lower its initial momentum
the greater this angle now let's go back
to circular motion imagine a satellite
orbiting Earth its velocity is as we
showed before at all times tangent to
its circular path a centripetal force
from gravity continuously swings its
velocity around so that every 90 degrees
it starts pointing
more and more in the opposite direction
it used to be just like with the ball a
downwards force won't send it straight
down instead the vectors combine
resulting in a new path like this 90
degrees ahead it reaches the maximum
distance it will travel in the direction
of our force before going back the key
point here is that a downwards force at
this location didn't move the orbit like
this it moved the orbit like this
tilting it 90 degrees ahead of where we
acted now imagine the satellite as a
small piece of our gyroscope pushing
down here will cause the piece to assume
a path that would take it like this but
of course since the disk is solid in all
of its pieces quite rigidly push and
pull each other the gyroscope itself
tilts like this or if the gyro pivots
around a point below its center like
this if the gyro wasn't spinning pushing
it down here would have just caused this
to happen but when something is spinning
its component parts have other vectors
you need to consider
I learned a fun demonstration of this
from a great video by Matthias Wandel
this is a cardboard disc
I cut it out myself I can balance it on
the end of a pen just like this and if I
blow on the side nearest me it tilts to
me not very surprising but if the disc
is spinning and I blow in the same place
it tilts to the right and if I blow on
the side nearest you instead of tilting
to you well it tilts to the left if
instead of applying my force in one
location the whole time I instead apply
the force wherever the tilt is greatest
down well
the tilt will glide around and around
watch
[Music]
I've run out of air but the point is
this is exactly what is going on when a
gyroscope here on earth is spun up and
tilted the tilt glides around this is
called precession what's happening is
actually very similar to my breath
moving around except instead of my
breath it's gravity no matter how
perfectly upright a gyroscope is it will
not stay that way forever
any deviation no matter how slight will
allow gravity to form a torque a torque
occurs whenever a force rotates an
object around a pivot point if the disk
is spinning the effect of that torque
will move 90 degrees ahead in the
rotation like so but now the torque is
operating this way so its effect will
have to be felt 90 degrees ahead and so
on and well what do you know the
gyroscope processes now if it wasn't for
friction and air resistance and other
forces meddling with this disk it would
just process at the same angle forever
but of course well we live in a world
with friction and air resistance and all
that good stuff so the disk spins down
in the same way that a slower moving
ball is deflected with a steeper angle
as the disk slows down each piece of it
is given a steeper and steeper orbit
around the gyroscope tilts further and
further down until it hits the ground
and eventually slows to a stop take a
look at this bicycle wheel it's like our
gyroscope but bigger I have a string
tied to its handle right here so when
lifted like this a torque is applied by
gravity like so it's equivalent to a
force up here in this direction
and a force on the wheel down here in
this direction if I let go those two
forces will do their work okay pretty
predictable if I give this wheel
spinning there will be other vectors at
play a piece of the wheel moving say
counterclockwise or along with the rest
of the wheel down here will have a
velocity tangent to its circular path
but also a torque pushing it this way
that will cause its orbit like in our
gyroscope to move like this this force
will have its maximum impact 90 degrees
ahead in the rotation so the wheel will
turn like this but well there's still a
torque here pushing the bottom of the
wheel this way moving that 90 degrees
ahead we see that the wheel will just
keep turning and in fact that's what it
will do if I can get it up to a fast
enough speed then tada an even bigger
spinning object is the earth and we are
all on it strapped in by friction and
gravity for the ride a ride with some
surprising consequences a helicopter
can't just lift up off the ground remain
motionless and allow the earth to rotate
under it
doesn't work that way this is because
the helicopter the ground it used to be
on and the air all around it are all
also traveling with the Earth's spin but
if you had a magic paper airplane that
could be thrown really far and you
decided to throw it directly north to
your friend Earth's spin would come into
play no matter how dead-on your aim was
every time you would find that the plane
drifts a bit east as if pushed by some
mysterious force and likewise your
friend to the north would find that
their plane thrown south directly at you
would always drift a bit west this is
called the Coriolis effect you are both
on earth and you're both always north
and south of each
but in a day your friend nearer the pole
travels a shorter total distance around
it's less distance in the same time your
friend is moving slower than you your
plane meanwhile is spinning at your
faster velocity and it continues to have
this velocity after you throw it as it
moves towards the pole it finds itself
amongst slower and slower things so it
pulls ahead of them and drifts east in
the direction of Earth's spin your
friends playing meanwhile finds itself
amongst faster and faster moving things
that it falls behind there's a vertical
version of the Coriolis effect as well
an object suspended very high right up
above you will actually fall a bit to
the east
if dropped and anything you throw
straight up at it will curve away to the
west of it the higher up object whose
circular path around is bigger covers
more distance in the same time than you
these velocities don't just disappear
when things are dropped or thrown up so
you both miss your marks it's also why
the directly outward pointing force you
feel when spinning is fictitious your
inertial tendency to move in a straight
line takes you further from the path
you're on to where things have to have
higher velocities to rotate at the same
rate if you fly out long enough you'll
notice yourself falling behind your
original rotation pace not with it
always directly out finally lose weight
fast but not mass with this one weird
trick discovered by a Hungarian nobleman
and physicist people who think the earth
is flat hate him it's called the bush
effect in the early 1900's Baron Roland
von Hood Bush was looking at gravity
measurements taken on ships at sea and
noticed that readings were lower when
ships were travelling east and higher
when they were traveling west further
investigations found that yes in fact
when traveling on foot in a car on a
bike in a plane doesn't matter you weigh
less when traveling
and more when traveling west in fact an
airplane flying east at the equator
experiences an apparent weight reduction
of about 0.9 percent so if you want to
quickly lose a bit over a pound about
half a kilo get on that plane what
causes this effect well when you're
spinning with the earth you have a
linear velocity but gravity a
centripetal force is always resisting
this if gravity was turned off and the
earth remained whole you'd be flung off
on a tangent that rose above your usual
path for this reason your inertial
tendency to take this tangent path is a
sort of lift it's not enough to take you
off the surface earth doesn't spin fast
enough for that to happen but just as I
can lift something that's on a scale and
make it weigh less without completely
removing it from the scale so to does
your inertial path lift you just a bit
traveling east adds to the velocity
Earth's spin gives you and provides more
of this kind of lift in a direction away
from the surface making you lighter
conversely traveling west decreases your
velocity in that direction lowering its
lifting effect on your weight I will be
thinking about this and maybe even
weighing myself very precisely while I'm
traveling the country with brain candy
live you got your tickets already right
don't wait it is very very exciting and
I cannot wait to get a chance to see you
all in person and be more interactive
with this kind of stuff and do so on a
much bigger louder personal scale also
subscribe to the curiosity box for more
mind dynamite it's fantastic and it
helps a very very good cause I so fully
stand behind it I'm very proud of it and
you know what go subscribe to dong while
you're at it my latest video there is
all about some of my favourite free
physics simulators on the Internet
you are all great I appreciate your time
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]